Okay so I think that was almost it,
was there anything else?
>> Yes, we then made a leap
to Monte Carlo tree search.
>> I wouldn't say it was a leap.
>> We climbed a Monte Carlo tree.
>> Yes, and did some search, and
what did we learn about
Monte Carlo tree search?
>> So it's really important to help
with scaling because it let's you
have computation that's independent
of the size of the state space
Even though it depends very possibly
badly on the length of the horizon.
>> Right so it's got a low o on
the state space practice independent.
But it has a big o on the horizon
which I'll just call h here.
>> And it's exponential with m.
>> Yeah it's exponential with m.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It looks like hydrogen now.
So does MCTS and
abstraction fit together in any way?
>> We could make it if
we were abstract enough.
If you pop back up far enough
you can sort of think of it as a kind of
abstraction over actions and policies.
>> But no I was thinking in particular
that the idea that in MCTS the way
we talked about it, it was talking about
specific states ground level states.
Like if we have a good way of
abstracting states can we use those
abstract states in an MTCS context.
>> Sure.
In fact,
what I was about to say is that all
of the stuff that we learned about
generalization up here can apply
to MCTS more easily than others.
Doing the function approximation
is sometimes quite hard, but
not really because of the way that we're
sort of thinking about the q functions.
But the temple abstraction works
very well because I can use
options instead of
actions to do my MCTS.
>> Right, you said that.
>> Yeah I said that.
And as a result
the state abstraction and
the the goal abstraction can also
follow through there if you think about
each of the individual modules as
doing their own version of MCTS.
But MCTS is a very general notion.
So if I were trying to decide between
different modules that I might take,
it will look exactly like trying to
do the sequential decision making and
MCTS will work either way.
But the big temporal abstraction is
a huge win for MCTS because again all of
its difficulty lies in the link
to the horizon, right.
So if I'm able to search
far ahead in the future,
that lowers my effective horizon.
>> Nice.
>> All right.
>> So if these ideas are so
important for
scaling up do you do you feel like
they've contributed to, I don't know,
the ability of reinforcement,
learning to solve some real problems.
>> Yeah.
Absolutely.
No, these things actually
come up quite a bit.
They've been used in a lot of games.
MCTS has been used, well it's all in the
papers that the students have written.
But MCTS has been used to solve
a bunch of game problems in just my
own work as well as in
a variety of other things.
You probably know a few more
off the top of your head.
But really any time you have a huge
state space, or potentially a huge
state space, these kinds of interactions
turn out to be extremely useful.
Some of them are easier to
think about than others.
Function approximation is very nice, but
does have its own problem with
picking the right features.
Particularly, if you are going
to be non-linear about it.
Temple abstraction is
often quite useful because
people can help you come up with
things like options or constraints.
Goal abstraction has kind
of a similar flavor to it.
And because of those things,
the state abstraction helps.
Basically, anything that let's you
lower the number of states or
the effective horizon has to make the
reinforcement learning problem easier.
>> Nice.
Alright.
So there, scalability.
These things actually work
they actually are helpful and
this is a huge wide open field
in reinforcement learning.
In fact, to your point I'll just sort
of ended with this that I think that
reinforcement learning has gotten so
good at solving.
Kind of well thought out
grid like problems that.
The field is really interested in, and
increasingly more interested in figuring
out how to make it
work in the real world.
And these kind of techniques,
these abstraction techniques,
these scaling techniques,
become increasingly important as you
try to move it out into the real world.
So this is a good thing.
>> Wow, I'm glad you told me about it.
>> I'm about helping others.
So I think we're good.
So I guess, goodbye, Michael.
Until next time.
>> All right.
Yeah, see you then.